one story about your dad the the bet the
bet involving your brother do you know
this where I mean the the bicycle yes
like the boat oh yeah
another way my dad did great business
ringings are so similar
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so my dad's at a ranch one time with his
friends they've been deer hunting all
day and it's late at night they're
sitting down at the bar and drinking
this stuff and all of a sudden the
subject comes up over how high everybody
can pee you know how and he's got this
buddy named Jim who's about six foot six
and they're playing cards looking around
and my dad sees this old BMX bike and we
couldn't afford a BMX bike now my middle
brother had been wanting a BMX
motorcycle but we couldn't afford it
there's this old CRX 80 over there and
dad says or you know Jim my son he could
pee over your head on the wall there's
no way you can do that and he goes yeah
you can't I'll bet y'all bout by bit the
up at the motorbike come on the guy goes
now there's no way I'm six foot six pop
gets in the car drives an hour and a
half back into town wakes my 12 year old
brother up in his tiny rhymes gets him
out of bed what do you got to do and you
get woken up in the middle night as a
kid you got a pee right did my dad says
no no no have a sip on this beer if
we're head and work about to go we're
about to go get yourself a motorcycle
buddy so there's Tyler as he write an
hour and a half back you're back at 4:00
in the morning and brings my brother the
barn hey put Jim up against the wall Jim
marks the mark at six foot six and my
dad says go ahead boy put the CRX 400 in
the back of the truck got home my dad my
brother's first motorcycle
a young entrepreneur weren't you I
wouldn't say that but didn't your father
get what did he eat he wanted you to
sell was its elevating what you do so my
parents came upon a truck of cellophane
somehow I was asked not to ask too many
questions I just I just suddenly there
was a basement filled with cellophane
and they encouraged me to go to school
and see if I could sell it to my
teachers or put a few in my backpack and
try and hock them at recess convince
kids that they might be good stocking
stuffers for their parents what do you
mean oh what's the use of silver high
yet I'd know the name but I don't know
what you do with it you know you wrap
sandwiches in it it keeps things fresh
oh I'm sorry
it was an important question yeah
I'm not doing a good job of selling it
obviously but did you said it there's
still some left if you're interested
nice and some of the dream was someone
would just say I'll take all of it
never happened it's a weird story it is
a bit weird it is a rivalry there's
bound to be a kite particularly Brooklyn
now he's 16 he's becoming his own man
and stuff this so funny like the way you
try to score points against each other
so Brooklyn put this picture up on
Instagram and he put on it rockin the
old school Ralph Lauren and look at that
he's got three hundred and seventeen
thousand likes okay so you know cool in
his Ralph Lauren and he scroll through
the comments you know
oh yeah whatever but one of the blah
blah blah get down to this one and mr.
David Beckham that's my jumper
Oh lunch actually when that that came up
of my screen that he just posted a
picture of him and it was my jumper so I
had to tell him but I do find him going
in my wardrobe even though he doesn't
think I'm that cool dad I still find him
wearing my clothes every single day
this one's beautiful so this is him it's
a little video he posted on Instagram to
really boast about the number of his
followers here we go so it's my mom's
birthday today okay I just reached a
million followers 52
[Applause]
[Laughter]
just about out the door and I could hear
him talking in his room and I thought
and then I heard him say you know I'm
just about just reads a million so you
destroyed that boy you know when we were
out he gets recognized so much that I'm
literally you know I'm known as
Brooklyn's dad now takes a picture the
son did such an amazing job playing you
I mean that's what I'm most proud of you
know more than having this movie have
Australia Compton this that now there is
the fact that my son was able to take
our opportunity and run with it and
hopefully set himself up and you know
one of the greatest industries in the
world and you know I'm so proud just as
a father and oh yeah you know it was a
movie about NWA too you know
how much did he know like when he was
doing scenes was he gonna you did this -
yeah in the hotel rooms you know some of
them say
man y'all was doing the most favorite
scenes too but he but he did no I mean
because how old was he when he knew the
lyrics to [__] out of Compton
oh that was young man you know my kids 2
3 playing all the time and you know they
would wrap it in sensory self you know
just they were like rap the list right
outta compton crazy my name Ice Cube
from Lori you've got kids but none of
them have followed in your footsteps no
they all do proper jobs yeah they all
did a bit they all tried it and we're
good at it actually I thought but but
didn't want to I I just think it's an
amazing thing to think of your son doing
this because I you know most men are in
some version are trying to try to play
their father anyway you know either
imaginary or real they're trying to sort
of play the role of their father until
they find out you know if they ever do
some some don't if they ever find out
who they are I think that's just an
incredible thing I mean I had a Barry
this is a very very sort of mild version
of it because I was playing I spent
almost 10 years playing a doctor and my
father was a doctor and I felt like I
was I was a fake version of what he
really was and I felt always sort of
constantly guilty about that because I
think I think a lot of men do actually
grow up feeling like that feeling like
fake versions of their own and until you
you hopefully get to a point where you
can think well I am I am the real thing
in some form you know it's whatever it
is it's real and what and this film is
got to put to bed all those things about
Aquaman because Aquaman up to this point
in the DC world what was a slight he's
like her a fun yeah yeah they made fun
of him then I was hired to which I feel
like I should win an award yes
you should like the lamest superhero and
kind of made him cool because in the
comics he was not that cool this is my
exec Snyder told me man and that's the
image that went through my head I've
seen this picture I mean it's the origin
of what we're a crow man came from it is
you got to see what he went through as a
child and his mother and Cole Kidman she
was here a few weeks ago yeah yeah so
yeah you get to see where he comes from
and I think a lot of people can relate
to it in this day and age and also
what's great is and you watching it must
have got the same kind of thrill that we
do because it's worlds we haven't seen
before you're blowing them up but we
have them seen them before and
presumably when you watch the film
you're thinking oh I didn't know that
was going to look like that yeah it's
even better cuz I haven't seen it yet
so it's gonna be like no wait a minute
you are the star of a movie and you
haven't bothered to watch it yet here's
the thing I have two babies that are
1011 there with me the whole time and
they promised me I wouldn't watch it oh
so they're so cute and they were there
with me the whole time and I'm like I
promise you guys will see it before all
of us yeah but my little crazy they're
on set with me and I just I want to hold
their hands and it's such a rare moment
being a father and Leslie for me cuz
generally you can't watch the things
that I do children should watch what I
do
Minnesota profession out of that and I
just feel like you know this is
something I want to share my children
just in case we get letters I should
well I hope say you haven't actually
tattooed your children Graham I haven't
tattooed my children that's alright
those are stickers you're disappointed I
was thinking that's pretty cool that'll
be watching that guy what if we want to
get a tattoo me and the answer that
question is an [__] is just a long
line of scumbags they did it with my dad
and we looked into his family and on one
side there was a philanderer who got
syphilis and gave it to his wife and
then they ended up in an asylum and then
we went to Wales and there was this guy
who was a Tory MP who had put down this
revolt of peasants that wanted the vote
and then he'd arrested like the William
Wallace of Wales and had him hung drawn
and quartered and I was doing it all
with my dad who throughout the entire
thing just had a completely blank
expression more upset
I am upset it's deeply depressing no
idea with the Welsh
[Applause]
- sobs I think we've got a picture of
you here just after you gave birth
no that's Charlie he's now almost
Three's two and a half and that's now -
we have River Joe who's one and he's -
now is it Charlie who's like a sort of
little mini-me well yeah yeah a little
bit a little bit I see you know you
start you say things and then they they
repeat them he says a couple of things
that I say my dad and this is probably a
regionalism used to say asses and elbows
meaning we'd be in the kitchen washing
pots and pans and if I if I participated
I'd be kind of mm-hmm and you come on
let's really get in their asses and
elbows so now Charlie I'm often in
charge of seeing him brush his teeth and
teaching him that that takes a while so
he kind of you known does a little bit
of this and I go come on asses and
elbows and he says it's fun to hear him
say asses and elbows I heard him say I
guess I said it he said oh yeah these
y'all I said you like those pancakes
yeah never in my whole life
what you say never bipolar Yuri over
three and a half years grace if your son
that seems remarkably unimpressed by
your career yeah yeah yeah he really
couldn't care less
there's nothing he doesn't believe
you're the real deal yeah I mean he's
now you know fatherless he'll say he's
five and three-quarters and he and he
went to Universal the other day
Universal Studios in LA theme park had a
good time and came back and he said hey
Dad guess what today I saw the real Owen
but I think there's this guy at a
universal who dresses up like my
character from the movie he's like does
this thing and the kids he's like no I
saw the real one day working is that
every day yeah
you obviously you know you you have your
parenting rules and all that but
apparently the what is it the parenting
rules change if you go fishing yes
that's right that's right we have a we
have I have a farm up in Washington
State and on on this farm is a lake and
and it's we fish a lot for bass on this
lake my son and I and I had this rule
with my old man and I have it with my
son which is when you're fishing you can
swear you can just swear when you're
fishing it's just the guys go ahead and
let loose and so we're out fishing he
catches a fish and I'm trying to get him
to take a picture with the fish before
we let it go and it flops out of his
hands and and these baths have these
little spines on on their back and the
fin pokes him in the hand and falls in
the water he starts to cry
and he's like oh ho and I said hey buddy
are you all right you all right he said
oh dad I'm about to swear hey you know
you know the rules and he goes that bass
that bass is stupid you know I think we
say hey don't say someone call someone
stupid that's bad you shouldn't say that
nice and he's continues to cry stitch do
you feel better he said a little bit
stupid stupid bass and I was like all
right buddy yeah you know now's the time
get it out and he goes
stupid basses of [__] [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
you